starting off this hour is brianna in
austin texas hi brianna welcome to the
show how can we help
hi dave first of all you're my idol my
hero and i love you dearly
and i'm so excited to talk to you you're
very sweet i'm about to let you down how
can i help
no no you will not i know you won't so
um
my husband and i are in baby step two um
we've been on your program
for a year it's our year anniversary
since we took your uh
financial peace university at
celebration church shout out
pastors joe lemore champion who are
amazing they're good friends they're
wonderful people
yes they are so here's the thing so i
just celebrated
my birthday and we went back home to
california
and one of my closest friends since high
school
has become extremely wealthy he works at
zoom
and has built quite a quite a wealthy
empire
through them and my husband and i have
been struggling to get pregnant
um for the last three years and we saw
fertility doctor and they basically said
that
at this point um doing ibs is our only
shot but we
never did it because we're trying to pay
off debt and i'm not going to go into
debt
as much as i want a baby to do this so
i've left it in god's hands
and my best friend gifted me twenty
thousand dollars for my birthday
to get ivf that the the
stated gift was for ivf
well he wrote us a check i know but did
he say
he said the check is for your birthday
or your check is for ivf
and your birthday it's to you it's all
of the about to use
towards ivf because they know you know
that we couldn't
afford it so they wanted to bless us
with that okay so what's your
question my question is we're in baby
step two
um and i just i i part of me wants to
put it towards our debt but
this is a huge blessing and our time is
of a of a concern with with my
my situation so i kind of just want your
thoughts on using that towards ivf and
continuing to pay off debt on the fight
um okay let's change the let's change
the scenario
and see how our critical thinking skills
work on this and i'll go with you
because i'm trying to figure out a way
to think through this okay
let's say that uh this friend gave you
20 000 paid for car
okay and he said because i think you
need a nice car
and you were saying my car is a hooptie
uh my car sucks
and so he just gave you a car for twenty
that's worth twenty thousand dollars um
the person giving the gift
said this is what the gift is
they didn't say now take the car go home
and if you want to sell it and pay it on
your debt you can do that they just said
no
i want to buy you a car
you probably wouldn't sell that car
while you're in baby step two
you probably just fight on through baby
step two right
absolutely because the giver of the gift
said
this is the definition of the gift
that's what i'm basing that on does that
make sense it makes
perfect sense now if it was bizarre and
they said here's a hundred thousand
dollar car
i would go whoa dude i need to get out
of debt would it be okay with you if we
did something different i would call
time out right
but if they just this is not a how much
debt have you got left in your baby step
two
38 000 what's your household income
uh after taxes we bring home about 85
000 and how much have you paid off so
far
uh about 30. way to go
so proud of you yes sir how quick did
you do 30.
in a year i mean it's it's so you got a
year
you got 14 months left yep exactly
and this is just an unfound blessing
that just dropped from the sky god yes
god blessed us
i think the giver of the gift told you
what to do with the gift
and i think we have to honor that
okay and i'm do i'm not doing that
because of the emotion around this or
because your clock's ticking or all of
those things
because i figure you know 15 months is
probably not going to decide whether you
have a baby or not
right so your clock ticking is not yeah
that probably doesn't cut it
because you're probably going to be
about the same ivf results 15 months
from now as you have today
i'm not a medical doctor but that's just
kind of common sense okay
yeah so uh but i'm with you i want to
have a baby babies are the best thing on
the planet
most of the time
[Laughter]
they're actually the best thing on the
planet if they're grandkids because you
can hand them back when they stink
yeah there you go i don't know how great
grandkids are going to be i've been
nicer to their parents
okay but um yeah so yeah yeah i get
yeah i um do this and
now i will challenge you just to do one
thing and that is to be very careful
in the ivf world uh like anything else
that is extremely important and noble
which the having of children would be
those things
um we the there's extreme amounts of
emotion around this and around adoption
consequently people get um
a wide variety of pricing
in the adoption world and a wide variety
of pricing in the ivf world
so you are now uh tasked with
studying that world and the pricing
structures and models from
various places not just one and
comparing them
to give you the best possible outcome
for the money that you have to spend
okay because there are all kinds of
deals that are
not priced properly and you're going to
come out of it really poor
and not have had the number of attempts
that you possibly could have had
okay i only know this because this has
come up a lot
in financial coaching over the years and
so i've seen
this price for adoption and that price
for adoption and i'm going you paid
50 grand and you paid 20. and both of
you adopted a baby
or you had unlimited attempts for
seventeen thousand five hundred dollars
uh or you got one attempt for seven
thousand five hundred
exactly and that's what's in your world
that you're getting ready to find out if
you get into this i just observed it
from the outside i know nothing about it
at all
except just looking at it it's i think
it's one of those things that people
don't ask
they just go because it's so emotional
and i'm challenging you to ask
gather data gather options and make a
wiser decision let's make this twenty
thousand dollars do what it's supposed
to do
god willing and so i think it's
incredible
it's an interesting and a great
discussion i get the exact same question
about adoption you know do i
do i stop everything into adoption uh
you know
well you know if somebody gives you the
money specifically for that yeah you
you're not stopping anything you're just
going to continue forward on it
but most of the time we're going to go
the other 14 months and be out of debt
save up and pay cash for the ivf or for
the adoption
and in every case it's probably the best
thing you could ever spend money on in
your entire life i can't think of
anything that
gave you greater return on investment
high quality of life
than babies for those that want babies
and
it's a it's a pretty fun stuff so
we'll be praying for you brianna that's
good it's good times